[Musique]
invité de sorgues ali ce matin serge
letchimy le président du parti
progressiste martiniquais bonjour d'hier
je lit chimiques bonjour et bonjour à
toute la martinique vous avez écouté les
propos d' alfred marie-jeanne de notre
journal notamment les propos concernant
le président de l'assemblée claude lise
que cela vous inspire-t-il
moi personnellement je suis très
préoccupé pour l'avenir
je me réjouis surtout pas de cette
histoire parce que ça peut déboucher et
je pense que ça va être le cas à une
crise institutionnelle extrêmement grave
au martinez vous rendez compte
le président de l'exécutif accuse son
allié président de l'assemblée c'est pas
n'importe quoi c'est comme si vous avez
un premier un président de la république
qui accuse son premier ministre pour
prendre une équivalence quoi et de de
trahir et de faire des manoeuvres contre
lui pour le faire condamner
donc le mettre en prison mais c'est une
accusation extrêmement grave
donc ça m'attriste parce que des
martiniquais n'avait pas besoin de ça on
a besoin surtout de projet développement
économique on est vraiment dans le
marasme le plus total dans ce pays là
rien n'avance tout est bloqué et à côté
de ça on a une crise entre deux hommes
non au coeur d'une institution je je je
sais pas s'ils lisent va tenir longtemps
si ma jambe va accepter que lise roy là
encore pendant longtemps le risque est
d'avoir des démissions ici à des
démissions cela veut dire que c'est une
explosion et et avec des élections
nouvelle je pense qu'il faut pas en
arriver là il faut absolument qu'ils
puissent eux se construit quelque chose
ensemble pour stabiliser le pays et
aller le plus loin possible
ils ont été élus ils ont demandé à être
réduits dont ils assument au samedi vous
avez tenu votre convention à saint
joseph il a notamment été question du
règlement intérieur de l'alliance plm et
de la relance du processus d'autonomie
d'abord parlons du règlement intérieur
fini la mise en congé du parti
oui parce que c'était pratique
c'est une tactique plutôt plutôt
qu'aider pratique qui consistait à
chaque fois qu'on veut faire quelque
chose qui correspond pas aux décisions
du parti de se mettre en congé
nok et puis après on revient mais le mal
est fait alors on a une situation qui tu
es on a créé une situation en soi qui
jurisprudence une pratique interne au
parti
c'est pas dans les statuts c'est pas
dans le règlement nous avons décidé de
mettre fin à ça le comité assure la cgil
a réuni la convention entériné bien sûr
il ya des situations les cas aujourd'hui
qui qui sont nées du fait que cette
pratique existait de ceux de mise en
congé du parti
donc il faut absolument arrêter ça et
être sérieux
ça veut dire quoi qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire maintenant qu'il ya qu
un seul chef c'est vous l'armée c'est
votre question de chef je suis pas du
tout de cette mentalité là on est un
corps d'activité avec un comité national
avec des militants des balisiers il ya
simplement une structure il ya une seule
maison il n'y a pas cinquante maisons en
ceux qui sont à la fois un pied dedans
un pied dehors un viol à julio par là
s'est terminé quoi quand vous voyez le
nombre de départs et de mise en congé du
parti
en même pas un an daniel robin dany
chaumet fred lordinot il écopait manuela
clermont désir qui en passe de devenir
la prochaine députés puis le cas yvon
pakit qu'il faudra régler
vous ne vous dites pas que qu'il ya un
problème de management de gestion
d'organisation de fonctionnement quand
vous avez cité des noms là on a chaque
classe est une tactique c'est une
stratégie c'est une position personnelle
ce sont des stratégies individuelles
norme et qu'il faut respecter je ne
condamne personne je considère que
chacun a le droit de 2,2 faire ménage
ailleurs ou de prendre une position de
se sentir blessé de ne pas être d'accord
ou telle position
et si c'est ça montre bien que le parti
poésie martin guay bien vivant il faut
respecter ces personnes qui ont décidé
de conduire d'autres combats et c'est
pas pour cela qu'on les considère comme
des ennemis et non absolument pas
d'accord est ce que le droit de tendance
vague doivent à exister au sein c'est
exactement ce que nous avons indiqué
pendant cette convention lorsqu il y à
un différent puisqu'il n'y a plus de
possibilité de se mettre en congé du
parti
eh bien on traite tous différents dans
la maison on traite pas le différend à
l'extérieur il ya une pratique un petit
peu individualiste qui s'est développée
de traiter des différents brutalement à
l'extérieur ça n'a pas ça n'a pas de
sens il faut créer une tendance si on
n'est pas d'accord sur une ligne
politique
eh bien on crée notamment s'ils ont des
bas mais autrement ça veut dire que
c'est une posture une position
personnelle et qui ne correspond pas à
l'esprit collectif qu'on veut inculquer
dans le parti autre point l'alliance
de vos mots même il faut reconstruire le
pnm alors conçu à peu et même ça passe
par quoi comment alors il ya il faut
dire que l'alliance nous a beaucoup
apporté si nous avons gagné la
collectivité régionale départementale et
les élections sénatoriales la députation
c'est parce qu'il ya l'alliance donc il
faut pas cracher sur les victoires que
il faut pas ignorer cela cependant on a
en fait le constat aussi que si nous ne
nous ne donnons pas un minium de socle
de penser devant d'orientation
économique d'orientation politique
qu'est ce que nous voulons ensemble
eh bien ça va être une alliance qui va
le kiki peu gonflé par des des
candidatures de port tunis mme et de
positionnement personnel et ça c'est pas
bien est ce qu'il va dire se souvient
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai entendu j'ai
lu sur le quotidien ce matin le maire du
lourd en disant qu'ils disaient que qui
l'alliance a du mal à fonctionner qu est
que l'alliance a du mal à se réunir je
termine ce que je disais alors je dis
clairement que et aujourd'hui il faut
donner une base un socle pas idéologique
au sens doctrinaire du thème mais sûr
que de penser et de projets et c'est
pour ça qu'on parle de reconstruire le
parti pour glisser martin quand le sel
est un parti autonomiste
d'ailleurs vous allez y arriver nous
faisons des produits sont extrêmement
claires nous avons adp des choix
économiques et sociaux que nous faisons
il faut absolument reconstitué pour que
ceux qui se sentent concernés sera avec
nous maintenant
l'alliance fonctionne bien sûr ce serait
souhaitable que tout un chacun chaque
fois qu'il ya une invitation puissent
être présents puissent participer au
débat mais cette alliance fonctionne
donc nous allons réunir tout le monde à
partir du texte que nous allons élaborer
et savoir comme en ont reçu sont
l'alliance pour l'avenir
est ce à dire que
les nouveaux partenaires de l'alliance
devront partager la test d'autonomie du
ppm non on en n'est pas là et de dire
absolument que tout le monde doit être
des autonomistes
mais si on est aux antipodes de la
position du parti progressiste
martiniquais je vois comment je vais
m'allier avec quelqu'un qui se situe aux
antipodes
si pas possible de s'allier avec
quelqu'un de droite par exemple on peut
d'ailleurs c'est le cas on a tu as mangé
du lys qui est une progressiste de
droite je suis très heureuse que je ne
lui soit avec nous et jusqu'à présent
avec pierrot petit mes bras la clé
république a certainement pas écouté je
veux l'autonomie je veux absolument que
les martiniquais ce soit au connu en
tant que peuple c'est d'ailleurs une des
résolutions prises dans leurs
conventions et je vais me mettre avec
quelqu'un qui ignore ça complètement
cette espèce de battre nadal qui a eu la
leur en décembre 2015 qui conduit à la
catastrophe du jour lui quand vous
mettez des gens qui ne pensent pas du
tout de la même manière et qui sont aux
antipodes comme ça explose abandonné
c'est pour ça que l'alliance ne surtout
pas suivre ce genre de schéma que faites
vous des morts de kpn convergence
progressiste martiniquais et
des membres de kpmg pense notamment à
fred lordinot qui siègent à l'assemblée
est ce qu'ils font pour vous toujours
partie d'un ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle avec apm je connais pas je ne
sais pas non ce sont ce sont des ans et
nous avons franchement je connais je
savais pas qu'il y avait kpm je ne
savais pas du tout là écoutez vous avez
cité le ferait de fred reste quelqu'un
que je connais très bien un gros bosseur
on verra d'accord vous ne pas fermer à
une négociation avec kpn écoutez je
voulais même entraînés vers le vide
un petit peu comme ceux qui veulent
remplacer le vide par le vide j'ai
entendu et des prospectives de dire il
faut absolument placer le vide qui lie à
la ctm parle du vide à construire en
fonction des opportunités de chacun le
vide pour vous si le g20
pour moi c'est le vide et c'est le texas
est vide mais bien sûr comment écouter
bien sûr idéologie qui a une base de
données et à une philosophie politique
il ya un projet économique
c'est un rassemblement d'individus qui
peut et permet de construire la
martinique où sont les perspectives que
fait on des enjeux clés comme le
changement climatique le développement
durable la mutation énergétique la
mutation numérique on n'en parle pas du
tout on dit simplement à nous rassembler
colophane boulot pour pouvoir présenter
connu contre le vide le vide contre le
vide ça donne toujours le vide pour
terminer
on voulait relancer le processus
d'autonomie relancer le débat
institutionnel sur l'autonomie s'agit
pas de relancer le débat institutionnel
pour se faire plaisir
emmanuel mâcon a décidé d'ouvrir des
perspectives de changement
constitutionnel
ça va se faire au cours de l'année 2018
nous sommes partis autonomistes
très tôt on a posé des bases d'autonomie
alors je vais être clair il faut se
référer aux disques ou des trois voies
de cette liberté d'aimer 678 entre
l'indépendance
nous ne sommes pas indépendantiste le
répète parce qu'elle n'a le monde qui
fait quoi de noix dans un schéma
novartis entre l'indépendance et
l'assimilation départementaliste nous
avons toujours plaidé ccr pour une
troisième solution une alternative une
troisième voie l'autonomie bien sûr la
perspective et d'autonomie en voilant
certains pays
comment ça évolue ça risque d'évoluer
positivement je pense aux corses
éventuellement et cette autonomie ne
nous avons dit que c'est un schéma
progressif de responsabilisation dans le
cas de la république française c'est à
dire dans le cadre de l'article 73 et
c'est dans ce sens que nous avons posé
des bases
il faut un que dans le cas de cette
réforme constitutionnelle qu'on
reconnaisse la population martiniquaise
comme peuple la deuxième chose il faut
absolument qu'on a une possibilité
normative permanente pour adapter la loi
et le règlement sur place martinique la
troisième chose il faut absolument
donner la possibilité de légiférer et
globalement de telle sorte qu'on puisse
avoir un écosystème économique qui nous
permet de développer ce pays
serge letchimy je vous remercie merci
d'avoir été notre notre invité bonne
journée l écoute de nos programmes
merci